over 10 000 years ago humans began to
live in settled societies
and ever since then we've needed to
build structures
to house ourselves to store our goods
to honor the gods
earth in construction is fairly easy but
uh not very strong
wood is better but it tends to catch
fire
brick and stone are stronger still and
they're fireproof
but how do we build with them we can't
just stack them up we need to stick them
together
we need some sort of rock glue an
adhesive that's as strong as stone
itself
or as long as i'm dreaming why not uh a
liquid rock that we could just pour into
molds and make in any shape we wanted
well this futuristic sci-fi technology
actually exists today in fact it's been
around for millennia
it's called cement you probably think
cement is boring
i am here to convince you that it is
pure magic
how does it work well uh oh
it is uh actually one of the uh oldest
crafts cement
is older than uh pottery older than
metal working
probably even older than agriculture
cement floors were found at this
agricultural site in turkey gobekli tepe
from 9 600 bc
cement begins with limestone a
sedimentary rock formed from crushed
seashells
the main ingredient in limestone is
calcium carbonate when you burn it
it gives off co2 and leaves behind
carbon
uh calcium oxide calcium oxide is a
caustic powder if you touch it it will
burn you
if you pour water into it it gives off
heat in an exothermic reaction in fact
enough to boil the water
uh the result of uh leaving behind
the water in the calcium oxide is called
slaked lime or hydrated lime
and if you pour that into a mold and let
it open to the air for a little while it
will absorb co2 from the air
and set as hard as stone the lime cycle
is complete
the powder has turned back into rock now
a pure lime cement like this
isn't very strong but if you add sand it
makes a mortar that you can
use to stick bricks together if you also
add pebbles and gravel
you get concrete which can be poured
into a mold
but we can make an even better cement
the ancient romans discovered that if
you add volcanic ash to the lime
you get a cement that will set even
underwater very useful for making
harbors
uh this cement uses a different
chemistry by the way which we don't
fully understand today the romans were
masters of concrete they used it to
build the aqueducts
the colosseum the pantheon and of course
all these structures stood for 2
000 years they're still around today
in the 1700s the eddie stone lighthouse
was rebuilt by john smeaton a father of
civil engineering using a variation on
the roman formula
it stood for over a hundred years and
was retired only
when the rock underneath it began to
erode
but we can make an even better cement if
you get your kiln hot enough when you're
firing the lime and silica
the result will form very hard nodules
called clinker
these are very hard to grind so they
were originally discarded as a waste
product
but if you do grind them you the
resulting powder is a cement that is
stronger than any other formula
it's called portland cement and it's
still the main type in use today
ever since it was invented in the 1800s
now all of these cements have a drawback
they have a lot of compressive strength
but they don't have a lot of tensile
strength
uh this is why the roman's built with
mostly domes and arches
uh the round shape of the arch directs
forces into compression
along the arch the medieval builders did
a similar thing they used the pointed
gothic arch which can stretch even
higher than the round roman ones
to prop up the high walls of their
cathedrals they used the flying buttress
all this making up for the deficiencies
of the concrete
but today we can do even better with
modern technology we can combine
uh concrete with another material that
has high tensile strength namely steel
the combination of the two is called
reinforced concrete and those
reinforcing bars are called naturally
enough
rebar there is a drawback
uh reinforced concrete does not last
nearly as long
the steel inside it eventually rusts no
matter how well you seal it away giving
it a lifetime of only about 50 to 100
years
compare this of course to the 2000 years
of the roman concrete
but it's a trade-off with reinforced
concrete we can build structures
unlike anything the romans could build
such as the cantilevered decks of
falling water
or the elegant half shell of the sydney
opera house
that is cement we crush and burn rock
extract its powdered essence and then
reconstitute it later
in any shape we choose like coffee or
instant pancake mix it is instant stone
just add water thanks everybody i'm
jason crawford